人生海海，各有精彩。
世界很大，但最远的旅程是走向自己。
希望每一次出发，你都有我们的陪伴。
出发计划。
大家好，欢迎收听新一期的出发计划。我是周周。
我是老吴。我一直非常羡慕一个职业，就是老师。
这个职业不论在任何国家都很受人尊重吧，应该。
最爽的是超长假期，是让打工人和牛马都羡慕不来的。
对于我们业外人士来看，也是一个非常有成就感的事业。
毕竟你通过教育改变大家的未来，价值观的树立是通过你在学生时期一个很好的老师带给你的。
当然，周周说的假期也是我最羡慕的原因。
今天这期节目，我们邀请到的一位嘉宾，就是一位体育老师。
请Ace给大家做个自我介绍。
大家好，我是Ace。
Ace，Ace，你们可以这么教我。
大概先帮Ace去说一下她挪威的整个行程。
一个人背着背包，在北欧待了整整20天。
这趟走的也确实是有点硬核。
从首都的奥斯路出发，一路向西，到斯塔万格，然后到比尔根奥达。
这一段是挪威最有名的所谓三大石路线。
我在看Ace的行程之前，那三块石头在很多照片上面都见过。
但是我没有完整的去了解过，原来它是一条很成熟的图路线。
而且是需要一定的体力的。
而且她走完了这个以后，又一路北上，进了罗佛敦群岛。
这里面就是电影里面，才有那种渔村，雪山，还有午夜的阳光。
在那爬了几座山，在湾北，托罗姆瑟，北极圈里面的地方，
在那还看了一场足球赛。
这个是不是体育老师才会想到这一点呢？
最后他又顺路去了冰岛，看了冰川，火山，还有黑沙滩。
所以大家应该知道了，这个就是咱们周周最向往的那种旅行方式。
一个人长时间户外，而且是自由随性的去观察这个世界。
Ace，你是一个什么样的性格呢？
一个人的这么长时间的旅行，其实不是所有人都能做到的。
我个人认为我的性格还是比较清烈。
我看我一本书叫《清烈的内在》，我觉得这个词蛮适合我的清烈。
换一个词就可能就是一个比较平静的人吧。
在前采的时候，我问Ace你的MBTI是什么？
她说，哎呀，我没有测过MBTI。
可能是STJ，或者SFJ这类的。
肯定后面是个J，对吧？
如果不是这一人的话，可能也没有办法去做这么详细的这么长时间的一个旅程规划。
Ace，你在小的时候就是一个这么清烈的人吗？
一半一半。
就是平时的时候，我真的是比较安静的一个人。
但是在跟体育相关的时候，练体育的时候，或者是体育比赛的时候，我就非常意眼。
就是非常笨犷的一个人，有点矛盾，但同时也并不矛盾。
他是一个情绪的书发口。
那你第一个上演的运动是什么？
当然是篮球了。我特别爱篮球。
最喜欢的那个球星是谁？
老柯柯比。
他是我的一个精神的寄托。
Gobie Bryant，哎，那也是我的。
他要九六黄金一代吗？
几岁开始喜欢看NBA的？
小学四年级的时候，开始看NBA的。
但那个时候我其实一路都是练田径的。
然后从四年级的时候，感觉自己好像特别开始喜欢篮球之类的。
现在的NBA对比你之前刚开始喜欢NBA时候的样子，你更喜欢哪一个时代呢？
原来的样子，更有意义。
喜欢上了篮球，现在的职业是一个体育老师。
这个之间是有必然的关系的吗？
嗯，并没有必然关系。
其实我读大学虽然是体育师伴专业，
但是我那个时候并没有说想要成为一名教师。
但是后来就英差扬错，还是成为了一名教师。
本身我是做篮球裁判的，
然后一直走的就是各种，比如说国际赛事，国家比赛，或者洲际赛事。
坚持了十来年吧，后来觉得自己还是想沉下来做一些其他的事情。
可能觉得那个时间已经到了，到了那个节点了，那个毛点。
我应该要去改变一下自己或者是要离开这个圈子。
也有可能我三分钟热度啊。
跟之前对比的话哪一个更好一些呢？
之前的话，我感觉就是自己在舞台上的感觉。
很多方面的能力都要很出色，然后你要负责出错了，
你要全权承担就是一个非常兼具的一个职业，我个人这么觉得的。
但是现在呢，我感觉我更加自由了。
这里的容错率也更大，教导学生这是必须的，
但是教育的环境对于一个人来说容错率更大一些，
就是没有那么大的压力。
裁判的一次物财或者是任何一个举动，
可能都是被人计较的，精神压力会更大一些对吧？
是的，然后就是前几年不是亚运会在杭州吗？
然后我就是竞赛部的，篮球竞赛部，
从早到晚有时候还是通宵好几天都在处理赛事，
处理国家队，处理裁判，处理交通，处理餐饮，处理住宿。
网络各方面的信息不能出一点差错，
那个时候就是很崩溃的一个状态，说实话。
我觉得与其说是崩溃的哭，
不如说是沉默的哭，来得更猛烈一些。
还是挺为你做体育老师开心，
毕竟你又有更多的时间去感受自己的生活了，
而且没有那么大压力。
是啊，我有更多的时间出去旅行。
比如说咱们今天要说的这次挪威啊，
你规划挪威的这场行程是很久之前的事吗？
其实我一直很想去走三十，
但是规划就规划了五天，
因为我要做签证的时候，
预约的签证就给我那么一个礼拜的时间，
所以我做规划做了五天。
平时也是一个特别高效的人吗？
确实。
做这个攻略之前，你对挪威大概是什么样的印象？
内敛，平静，素颜，没有过多的修饰教育国家，
就是给人一种极致的自然和克制的复族感的一感觉。
听着都是超级好评啊。
如果形容一个人的话，
就是感觉他是全素颜的，没有化过妆，
这样会不会更加的口语化一点？
嗯，很贴气。
大概是去年还是前年的时候，
挪威国家旅游局做了一个他们的宣传片，
片子里面就极致地呈现了他们自然里面的种种美景，
跟新西兰那种纯净还有一点区别，
因为在挪威会感觉自然的冲击力会更大一些，
因为它有更多的元素，
就比如说狭弯啊，冰川啊等等。
这次去挪威和冰岛，
去看一下中国唯一没有的地貌，狭弯。
旅行当中，让你觉得最震撼活动影响最深刻的，
是这个没有的地貌吗？
有自然环境，也有人与人之间的沟通，
一些善意的举动。
最重要的是，在每次旅行中，
我都可以无数次地走向我自己。
遇到新鲜色的人，
体验很多有趣的东西，
不断探索吧，
然后让自己不要太傲慢，
就是这样子。
有时候我也会傲慢，会骄傲嘛，
但是我看到更宏大的世界之后，
我就会缩小我自己，
因为我实在是太渺小了。
到了挪威之后，
你印象很清晰地遇到的第一个人是谁啊？
到了奥斯路落地之后，
火车上就看到一位老奶奶拿着书在看，
这就是我的第一个印象。
很少有人在公共场合，
坐着看一本纸质书了，
是不是？反差特别的大。
北欧的人，
就是像刚刚老吴说的一样非常克制，
他会人与人之间会有一种距离感，
边界感，
他们描述的是他们尊重所有人，
所以害怕去打扰别人，
所以他们也变得非常平静。
不仅仅是奥斯路，
其实整个北欧，
他们城市里的基础设施建设，
是非常完善的。
公共图书馆，
可以用非常的豪华这两个字去形容，
书籍之多，
服务设施之完善，
你可以看到下至四五岁的小朋友，
上至八九十岁的老人，
都可以在里面，
而且是不同的类型的座位，
有那种类似于自习的，
有那种可以交谈的，
有沙发椅，
有木质椅，
也有那种很摩登现代的一些环境，
也有区域是提供给你喝咖啡，
吃点心之类的一些东西，
他们的洗手间也是，
公交车，大巴车，火车，
飞机等等等等等等，
都是有洗手间的，
连公交车都有，
然后公交车里面的洗手间，
和火车里面的洗手间，
特别干净整洁，也特别的大。
这样让我，我一定得体验，
一趟公交车里的洗手间。
对，值得体验非常干净。
奥斯路的公立图书馆的管理员，
帮我写了旅行纪语，
我最后挪威完好，去冰岛完好，
我又费回了奥斯路，
再请这个图书馆的管理员，
给我写了我旅行结束的纪语，
这也是我印象比较深的一个。
介不介意把他的这个行前纪语，
和行后纪语分享给我们。
刚到那边的时候是一位黑人小哥，
他是那边的管理员，
他给我写的纪语是，
平时都不会有人去找到他，
跟他说话，当我找到他的时候，
他很惊讶，我愿意去和他沟通，
阅读是人一不可少的组成部分之一，
然后也很开心我能够，
每一次到城市都会选择图书馆，
去安静的坐一会儿坐半天，
这是黑人小哥给我写的。
结束之后，回到奥斯路，
那天坐班的是两位挪威的当地人，
是白人，然后我跟他们说，
哎，我上次来的时候，
是一位黑人小哥帮我写的，
他们说是哪位呢？
我说我也不知道，
但是我把时间告诉他们了，
日期，然后他们查到了之后说，
那位黑人小哥今天晚上也会值班，
但是由于我晚上要走了，
所以我就请这两位挪威当地人，
帮我写了，
然后他们也写的是，
他说很佩服我的勇气，
自己独自一个人背着包，
就完成了这样一次徒步之旅，
也感到很惊讶，
我能够从冰岛再回来，
这件事情，
因为从冰岛再回来，
本身就不容易了，
你已经来过奥斯路了，
然后你去了冰冰岛再回来，
其实是一个路程是非常遥远的，对不对？
来的时候，
花半天坐在了图书馆，
回去的时候，
又花半天坐在图书馆看书。
很多人在旅行当中，
并不会去关注当地的图书馆，
甚至是其他的一些公共基础设施，
都是把注意力放在各种景点，
各种辉煌的建筑上面，
图书馆恰恰是能够很好的。
深入当地生活的一个选择吧。
就在奥斯路高校的Ace，
在第一线的时候，
就已经刷完了三个地标地点，
有一个是让我特别感兴趣的，
就是门克美术馆，
因为这里面还藏着呐喊，
因为所有的人可能都看过呐喊这个画面，
但是身临奇境的时候那种感受，
Ace，你能给我们大概描述一下吗？
嗯，我去的时候还是比较幸运的，
呐喊不是有出座，
第二稿和第三稿吗？
他的稿并不是说，
每天都会给你呈现出来的，
我去的那天很幸运，
他就展出一个小时当天，
三稿都会同时展出，
我很好奇，
画家他到底脑子里在想些什么，
当他创作的时候，
我真的很想解剖他的脑袋说实话，
很神奇，
里面还有很多著作，
我印象比较深的是有关于性别的，
就是男性跟女性和关于爱这两个主题，
用色,
他的文理都非常的独特，
十二层楼，
每一层楼展出的作品都是不同的主题，
因为我每次去到一个国家旅行，
对我来说，
最重要的一个地方就是咖啡和甜点，
北欧的咖啡都是极浅红的，
适合手冲的，
然后我特别喜欢手冲咖啡，
所以我每到一个城市，
我都会选择一到两家咖啡店，
挺咖啡，
买我喜欢的咖啡豆，
吃我最爱的热柜卷和胡萝卜蛋糕，
这些都是北欧的专属，
意大利和法国的话，
可能是跟偏向Espresso，
就是意识浓缩类的，
然后北欧的话就是手冲，
手冲的特点就是，
如果你是浅红或极浅红的话，
它是会有一点酸调在里面的，
水洗在里面可能会有果香，
或者是一些酒香，
会可以品出来，
跟北欧的个性很像，
就是希望人静下来，
慢慢品的那种感觉，
如果是奥斯路的话，
就是所谓的世界第一咖啡店，
福岗咖啡店，
还有一个叫team咖啡，
可以去，
它是世界首冲冠军的咖啡店。
我们也会在shownote里面，
给你们名字，
第二天的行程，
也是一个城市，
我觉得如果感兴趣的话，
听众朋友也可以多关注Ace的公众号，
已经更新很多部分，
我们的重头戏，
先从挪威的这三大石开始，
大概描述一下这三石有多厉害，
第一个步道石，
它的一天往返差不多是8公里，
听起来对你的体力，
并没有要求的那么多，
但是也是一个4-5小时的徒步，
第二个奇迹石，
一个相当危险的旅程了，
路线中它是非铺装的路面，
而且是大量的岩石攀爬，
一次往返差不多是11公里，
总的爬升要800米左右，
这个时间耗时，
看你的体力，
可能你是需要8-10个小时的，
但是Ace应该是轻轻松松的，
在6小时之内完成，
3个半小时，
第三个石头，
Ace就更厉害了，
扭摸之石是28公里左右，
总的爬升也是800-1000，
正常我们普通人耗时，
是10-12个小时，
Ace是花了4个小时就完成了，
体能为什么这么强呢？
体能强，
首先就是，
一是从小练体育，
因为我是体育生嘛，
最重要的一点是，
我有徒步的习惯，
还有就是我知道，
我暑假里，
要去徒步了，
为其二十来天，
所以对我的体能是极大的挑战，
那么我就规定自己，
每周一山，
所以整个3月份，
4月份,
5月份,
6月份,
我雷打不动，
每周一山，
暴雨哦，
我都没有停止去爬山，
当然我不是推荐你下暴雨，
去挑战爬山，
但是我就是给自己，
硬性规定说，
每周一山，
杭州有很多的山，
那么,
其实我们可以走群山嘛，
叫做西湖群山路线，
比如说标易线，
然后五朝山的大金刚，
小金刚，
还有24生肖，
这都得亏于，
我觉得那些非常有趣的人了，
他们会开发很多的路线图，
然后我们，
就可以根据那个路线图，
去徒步，
你可以爬出，
鼠牛虎兔，
龙蛇马羊，
猴鸡狗猪，
还能爬出，
比如说，
鳄鱼啊，
爬出一朵爱心，
两个爱心，
心碎的爱心，
爬出比卡丘，
爬出女巫都可以有，
所以这就是我
每周爬上的乐趣，
画不同的路线。
四天三十的这个挑战，
对比像，
之前很火爆的大学生，
五天五月，
难度上，
这个会更加的具有挑战性，
挪威的这个，
一方面是体能，
另一方面也是心理，
另一方面还有极端的天气，
各种不确定因素加起来的话，
确实,
四天三十难度要高一些，
心理上确实，
比如说，
奇迹时，
你要站上那块石头上，
捧高,
或者是滑，
或者是像恶魔之蛇也是的，
你去那边，
因为你恶魔之蛇，
你只是去拍照，
还是还好的，
但是如果你要把脚放下去，
就是很恐怖的一件事情，
因为都是深渊，
而且路面是不是也不太一样啊？
五月基本上都还是台阶。
和那种铺装路面吗？
天然的岩石，
天然的峭壁，
恶魔之蛇，
还有一点点的土路，
奇迹时完全没有土路，
全部都是岩石峭壁。
嘉宾带我们跑到了。
厦门附近的一个野山去爬，
也是一样手脚并用的，
去攀爬巨石，
到最上面的时候，
有一个被他称之为。
信仰之月的段口，
两个石头之间是要险阶，
但是中间有一个空隙，
理论上是可以入跑，
并且跳过去的，
但是下面就是悬崖，
周周呢，
本来是想挑战一下的，
但是我在旁边就一直在说，
不行是可以的，
咱们也可以不用试这个东西，
周周慢慢的就被泄了气了，
然后站在那等了一会儿说，
我放弃了。
对，如果是A4在旁边的话，
我估计就跳了。
无关于能力，
能力是一方面，
另外的是你
永远无法想象，
下一秒会发生什么。
再有能力的人，
世界图部冠军，
登山冠军，
或者是那种跳伞，
各种极限运动，
都会有一些事故平凡发生，
这也是新门里能够看到的。
周周那时候放弃，
是正确的选择。
当你要做一件什么事情，
尤其是这个东西，
跟危险是挂钩的时候，
但凡有一丝的犹豫，
就不要去做。
也是提醒听众朋友们吧，
注重自己的安全为主。
尤其是你图部，
本来体能消耗很大了，
你再要去挑战一些危险的事情，
这时候你的身体，
可能跟不上你的思想了。
我敢去这样挑战，
也是因为，
之前我跟你们说过，
每周一山嘛，
那给自己规定的就是，
低于20公里，
然后还爬升低于1000公里，
那我就不会带任何食物，
然后水我就带半瓶，
高于25公里，水瓶25公里，
连续爬升高于1200-1500，
那我可能带个一瓶水，
如果图部大于25公里，
30公里的水瓶距离，
爬升大于1600-1800，
那我可能稍微带点，
帮帮糖啊，
或者是干粮之类的。
当然这是对我有一个，
很明确的认知啊，
我会这样去做，
就是不断的挑战极限，
挑战极限，
以确保，
假期20多天的图部之旅，
能够顺利达成，
你才有一个正确的自我认知，
你觉得你能够挑战，
那你就可以去，
像周周可能觉得，
哎，我可能有点害怕，
那就不要去，没关系，
又不是一定要去跨过那个缝隙，对吧。
长期的训练，
以至于你对自己的身体，
和消耗情况，
了解的非常清楚，
就像在了解一个机器一样，
这个好像也是，
你去做一些
户外和极限运动的时候，
具备的素质，
是,
精确的，
知道自己的能力，
在哪里，
自己的极限，
遇到什么危险情况，
你能否解决，
对于我和老吴来说，
就像是，
知道自己的酒量，
到底是，
几斤几两一样，
除了风景以外，
是不是你也收获到了，
很多与人互动的乐趣呢，
是的，那这是自然的，
分享一下吧，
在步道时的时候，
我是一个人，
独自登山的，
所以就没有什么，
跟人之间的交流，
但是在奇迹时和恶魔之舌呢，
都有一些，
或多或少交流，
奇迹时我遇到了，
一位,
来自法国的，
摩洛格小哥，
叫阿丹，
和一位，
在荷兰留学的，
深圳小弟弟QQ，
整个突破过程呢，
他们都一直跟着我，
所以我就说，
哎,
要不要一起，
最后都一起了，
虽然他们真的很慢，
他们也不会说我，
说我说他们的，
确实很慢，
我一直在等他们，
出不完之后呢，
这个法国的，
摩洛格小哥，
阿丹,
他给我写了一段，
寂宇,
这段寂宇，
我印象非常深刻，
他写的是法语，
我只能大致的，
去翻一下他的意思，
他是这么表达的，
在我30岁的时候，
从未感到，
自己拥有任何东西，
但是,
你有好奇心和探索欲，
并且能够即刻行动，
去追求，
时常感到有趣，
这很好，
在他的国家，
摩洛哥，
女性的地位，
依旧很低，
不知道你们的国家，
是怎么样的，
我想，全球都是如此，
但,
从和你的对话中了解到，
即使如此艰难，
你也没有妥协，
请你一定要，
坚持自我，
绝不放弃追求，
生活时常让我们，
感到焦虑，
但,
请允许我们，
自由发挥，
就是这样子的，
写好之后，
用英文跟我讲了一遍，
大概的意思，
就是这样子的，
反正,
我是维持动容的那个时候，
完全陌生人，
你们只是走了，
几小时的路之后，
他能有感而发，
他给你写这么多的，
掏心掏肺的话，
这个还是一个，
挺难得的认识吧，
对吧,
善意,
你们有，
在留下什么联系方式吗？
他并没有，
但是后面的恶魔之蛇，
有留一个联系方式，
这是,
我当时去徒步，
恶魔之蛇的时候，
遇到了一对英国父子，
爸爸呢，
叫什么名字我不知道，
但是儿子呢，
叫Mike,
那个时候，
Mike和我互相不认识，
但是我们俩就好像，
感觉在互相不断的比拼，
比谁快，
爸爸就一直落在后面，
然后我就直接说，
嘿,
你要不要等等你的父亲，
然后来我们就等他，
然后三个人就并假期，
并假期去，
一起登到了山顶，
这个老爷子，
带我真的像女儿一样的，
我到了山顶之后，
我就说，啊，
我想,
一定要喝到冰可乐，
结果一下山，
他就二话不说，
也没有问我就给我买了冰可乐，
很感动的，
在一个陌生的地方，
陌生的人，
把我像女儿一样对待，
他说,
他很少看到女性，
更少看到亚洲东方女性，
能够选择一个人，
背着包出来，
然后更难见的是一个人，
背着包出来涂布，
更更难见的是一个人，
二十多天这样子，
还四小时做完了，
全程,
其实刚才聊了那么多，
我一直在脑海里，
营绕不断的，
就是女性这个词，
就比如说，
像,
摩洛哥小哥哥，
在到英国的父子，
有没有可能，
真的女性，
没有道理想中的，
这个生活状态？
不仅你是这两位，
临时搭子，
我去各地，
各城市，
各地区，
都会有这样的陌生人，
我们的交流过程中，
他会表示对于女性，
对于,
亚洲人，
东方人，
亚洲女性，
这样一个状态的，
一个差异，
或者是惊喜，
或者是惊讶，
因为我每天都会，
经历这样的事情，
每天都会有陌生人，
可能是当地人，
可能是旅客，
听到我的那些，
叙述之后，
会很惊讶，
看到我本身就很惊讶了，
然后,
我在跟他们交流的时候，
听到我的，
整个旅程的安排，
我遇到的一些有趣的事，
他们也会，
更加,
差异。
你好像是，
一个女性力量的，
健行者一样，
甚至包括，
像你,
分职业，
求财,
在整个这个，
求财的这个圈子里，
我理解，
应该也是，
女性的裁判的，
数量,
或者是，
占比,
是相对少一些的，
是的,
我那个时候，
确实很少，
在英语里面，
man,
代表人，
他并没有说，
男人跟女人之分的，
所以,
我就是觉得，
我们跟男性一样，
男女,
真的是平等的，
不管在思想层面，
还是力量层面，
精神和肉体上，
都是平等的，
有能力完成的，
但现在的话，
其实还好，
我觉得，
不必要刻意证明什么，
在自己，
保持自我的同时，
偶尔的让别人印象深刻，
偶尔的改变一下，
别人的思维定式，
这可能是我，
旅行的目标吧，
我想让他们知道，
女性也是非常有力量，
非常正能量的，
我也想让他们知道，
我们中国人，
或者我们整个亚洲人，
也是非常有力量的，
让他们改变，
对我们的一些，
刻板印象，
没有那么刻意了，
刻板印象是，
需要更大，
更有力的一个反正，
才能让所有的人，
都闭嘴，
或者是真的，
改变认知的，
是的，我们必须要发声，
因为没有人，
那么愿意主动的，
去了解你，
西方人和外国人，
更加没有必要，
他们也不想说，
去很深刻的了解，
亚洲人，
了解我们国家的文化，
那我们怎么样，
打开自己，
让外界的，
世界的人，
让西方人，
了解到真实的样貌，
那就,
我们需要走出国门，
我们是需要去自证的，
我们主动跟他们，
沟通,
我们打开自己，
他们才愿意，
给我们交流，
在交流中，
产生碰撞，
原来如此。
大多数，
西方人，
都会觉得，
中国人的，
英文很差，
其实并不是的，
只是,
我们出门在外的时候，
大多数都是，
把自己包裹起来的，
并不太愿意，
去跟外界，
产生过多的交流。
我靠,
所有的老外，
跑到中国来的时候，
他只是说了一句，
你好，谢谢，
中国人，
他一个特别大的，
正向反馈，
就是,
你的中文说的，
太好了，
也是时候，
我们应该自信一把了，
就起码，
外语上，
我们是在，
实际上，
走得相对领先的。
像Ace这样，
身体例行的人，
现在也在，
慢慢的变多。
当然,
我们也是跑题了。
四天三十，
给了我很多，
画面感，
不光是，
自然风景，
或者是，
Ace对于这个，
盘盘的挑战，
也有很多，
其他的意义在，
挺丰富的。
刚刚不是，
四天三十嘛，
有个四有个三，
是跟我徒步相关的，
然后,
其实我在，
这次旅行中，
还有其他的数字，
比如说，
我自己数了一下，
我其实有四次落泪，
这个是被感动的，
还是被委屈的？
都有,
开始了哦，
第一次落泪，
是,
晚上,
从奥斯路，
坐过夜火车，
前往斯塔万格，
那么前往斯塔万格，
是准备徒步，
挪威骑士之一，
步道时，
和奇迹时的，
但是,
你知道吗，
那个过夜火车，
在半夜的时候，
停了很久很久，
原因是因为有人，
跳鬼自杀了，
一个年轻人，
男子,
一跃而下，
就这么走了，
所以我们的火车，
必须停下来，
停了很久，
我不知道，
为什么我们会停，
但是,
坐在我旁边，
那个当地的大叔，
告诉我的，
他还告诉了我，
挪威哦，
每年,
大概有六百人，
平均,
那个数字，
看起来很小，
但是,
挪威总人口，
数量才多少，
当时,
听到的时候，
我本来是很焦虑的，
我说我要去，
爬山来不及了，
来不及了，
我赶不上大巴了，
但是,
听到这个事情之后，
我就感觉自己，
特别难受，
很久很久，
难受了很久，
那个时候，
我都感觉自己，
不能呼吸了，
窒息,
整个人就是，
捂着嘴巴，
在那边哭，
怎么也止不住了，
当时我就想的是，
难道生命就，
没有任何意义吗，
就是这样，
即使在，
挪威,
幸福程度，
非常高的国家，
也是这样子，
就像刚刚，
老吴说的，
可能他们那边，
就是太平静了，
平静到，
没有一点波澜，
所以,
没有一点起伏之后，
人没有情绪，
就是一坛死水，
我,
因为我本身，
很喜欢看书嘛，
我有一本书，
叫《自杀论》，
翻译成，
作文版本的，
我看了七遍，
里面就有讲到过，
北欧人的自杀，
然后,
我感觉我这次，
就是,
真的体验到了，
北欧的自杀，
平时其实是一个，
很平静的人，
那这一次事件，
有没有对你，
冲击很大道，
觉得自己之后的，
性格和，
生活的状态，
也要有一点改变才行，
有很多，
就是,
我的性格，
是很难改变的，
因为是，
女生就来的，
就是一个，
比较平静的一个人，
但是,
你看我在国外，
也是很外放的，
对不对，
就是很涉牛的，
通过这次，
可能,
内力是平静的，
但是我有时候，
也要给自己添加一点，
让自己，
波光淋淋的感觉吧，
就是,
水面很平静，
但偶尔波光淋淋的感觉，
需要更多的打开自己，
愿意跟身边的，
朋友,
同事,
主动的，
沟通交流，
让我的生活和工作，
泛起一点水花，
这样子，
我可能就，
不会那么平静，
人太平静，
什么都不想，
也不好，
是不是挪威，
是能覆盖到，
极咒极业的呀，
自己,
也是很容易，
影响人的，
心理健康，
是的,
这也是，
这本书，
自杀论里面，
讲过的，
先天的，
可能,
基因力携带的，
还有后天的，
环境,
环境就是，
城市环境，
自然环境，
气候,
地形地貌，
等等,
都会影响到，
一个人的，
一个激素的，
分泌,
然后可能就，
对,
第二次，
落泪呢，
就是,
第三,
恶魔之蛇，
它那是晚上，
公交车是晚上，
九点发车，
会在凌晨的，
零点零五分，
抵达,
因为,
之前,
国内,
台风的原因，
所以我就，
不得不，
调整了，
这里的一些，
行程,
那导致我，
临时调整之后，
就没有，
住宿了，
因为,
这个二代，
调整是，
非常偏僻的，
一个小镇，
然后也没有，
什么住宿，
我只能，
然后,
一起,
车也,
入宿街头了，
鸡含胶铺，
特别冷，
还有就，
时不时，
有一些车辆，
经过,
有飙车的，
也有正常行驶的，
然后也有，
罪悍经过，
有车来，
加油啊，
还有,
我还被经历了，
被,
两辆,
摩托车，
萎水啊，
之类的，
所以我就，
不得不，
更换我的，
庇护地，
我在哪个地方，
一个角落里，
避风休息，
又睡不着，
然后我继续走，
走到一个超市的，
地下车库，
休息,
还是睡不着，
然后又走到，
两班米开外的，
一个居民楼，
楼梯间休息，
还是睡不着，
就是这样子的，
然后,
路过的人，
肯定都看到我了，
我的心理活动，
也挺自在的，
就不敢睡，
非常委屈了，
有一点小委屈，
然后也有一点害怕，
因为毕竟被委随了，
也有很多罪悍经过，
然后眼角就抹泪了，
因为我约的大拔车，
一辆接一辆，
我都是第一班车跟上的，
所以,
我觉得我当时的抉择是对的，
就是路途街头的角色，
是对的，
这边苦不算什么，
这得多焦虑啊，
是,
他蛮有意思的说实话，
幸好是急皱了，
天没有很黑很黑，
还是蓝掉的，
没睡没吃没喝，
去爬了恶魔之蛇，
四个半小时，
上山下来，
就成为了当天，
第一个下山的人，
天哪,
幸好遇到了，
英国父子，
吊动了我身体的躁润，
一开始，
我们听到，
你说,
常人十二个小时，
你花四个半小时，
就下来，
已经很惊叹了，
现在又加上了，
这个经历之后，
感觉你已经超神了，
当时我坐Shadow Bus，
坐我那个
玉丁的大巴的时候，
我其实是很困的，
但是当我看到，
这些一起徒步的人啊，
不认识的人，
以及上山之后，
英国的父子一起去徒步，
那么我就会觉得，
哎，他们就让我，
非常的适，
市场线急速分泌啊，
然后我就一点都不累了，
就这样，
我想我要证明自己，
我要证明自己，
很厉害这样，
第三次落泪，
即是暴风暴雨的一次徒步，
在罗福敦，
北边的斯沃尔维尔，
那么我在凌晨的时候，
在民宿里醒来，
然后看到一直在下雨，
那我当时就犹豫，
要不要去挪威奇石之寺，
叫做恶魔之门，
去徒步，
然后最终我还是决定出发了，
早上七点半的时候，
我抵达山脚，
还是大风大雨，
那么我在上升的时候，
没有看到任何人，
那时候就我一个人，
早上七点半，
然后我就鼓足勇气，
一直往上走，
先往右，
想去扬脚风，
是失败了，
因为实在是太滑了，
都是岩石，
泥泞的土，
抖翘的悬崖，
这是那边山的特色嘛，
岩石啊什么悬崖，
然后暴风暴雨，
就有好几次，
就把我整个人吹倒了，
然后我有两次是差点，
如果一不小心，
我就要坠下去的那种感觉，
大概十分钟吧，
雨越下越大，
风也越来越躁动了，
然后我根本动不了，
孤立无援，
然后我那时候只能这样子，
感觉就脱缩着，
这个感觉就勾搂着背，
然后一直在那边站着，
站着也不敢动，
然后眼泪就流下来了，
我感觉，
哦，我可能，
是不是我就要，
就这么没了，
雨稍微，
稍微小了一点之后，
我决定了，
我决定放弃，
然后我就过了很久，
我就小心翼的，
走到山脚了，
但是呢，
当我走到山脚，
就是,
我突然有了希望，
因为我看到了两位，
来自波兰的朋友，
一男一女，
他们是朋友，
看到他们，
我感觉看到希望，
然后最后我们三个人，
一起又上山了，
最后克服了一切，
然后我也看到了彩虹，
玉钟彩虹，
然后也抵达了恶魔之门，
还是蛮幸运的，
天气恶劣，
但是我看到了山中彩虹，
也很有幸跟这两位，
波兰的朋友，
再次登顶这样子，
但是我觉得是老天，
让我上去的，
因为我第二次上山，
看到了彩虹了呀，
风雨之后，
说不定那对波兰人，
也是老天给你安排的，
同伴,
对，安排的，
看不了同伴，
而且他们一个是律师，
一个是护士，
我又是老师。
第四次落泪呢，
其实不在挪威，
是在冰岛，
跟前面几次落泪，
有点不太一样，
就是,
那时候在冰岛，
我去斯奈山半岛，
去看景观了，
面对着一个草帽山，
我坐在一个瀑布石牙上，
向草帽山望过去，
一直沉默，一直沉默，
大概沉默了15分钟，
然后我就问，
那个时刻，
坐在我旁边，
有一个32岁的陌生姐姐，
突然有感而发，
就是我说，
姐姐，你说，
怎么才能证明我来过呢，
然后是不断的打卡拍照，
还是用文字，
寄入下来，
还是购买当地的，
纪念品作为收藏，
我的意思是，
怎么才能证明你的存在，
你在这里留下的痕迹，
我是这么问他的，
但是我也没有希望，
那位姐姐能够回复了，
我只是单纯的，
沉述我内心的想法，
其实我心里都心制度明，
我知道这些都不重要，
因为大自然，
从来不会留下任何痕迹的，
她要装载和包容，
太多太多，
宏大的虚实了，
因为我实在太渺小，
像一颗尘埃一样，
像我这么一个小小存在，
我能在我的心中，
给她,
给大自然留下一点痕迹，
我能证明她的存在，
但是大自然，
她其实永远无法，
不必要，
无需证明我的存在，
然后想到这里，
其实我又落泪了，
我感觉又是，
又是开始，
感觉又像一个闷蕾一样，
又像枪炮一样，
就一枪枪，
记住我的心头那个时候，
就感觉我被枪，
一直在那边打，
打我的心脏，
面对如此壮观的景象，
瀑布,
和一个这么大的草貓山，
我就开始，
又开始，
思绪泛滥了，
震撼的感动，
我的存在合不合理，
我是不是存在，
都是个疑惑，
因为我有时候觉得，
我根本就不存在，
就像宇航员一样，
因为宇航员有一个叫。
总观效应，
到了宇宙中之后，
看我们的地球，
然后,
发现我们地球
如此的渺小，
然后再回到地球，
之后,
整个人都改变了，
这新闻里也不过很多，
那这些人，
整个人都改变了，
这新闻里也不过很多，
那对于我们来说，
我们不可能像宇航员一样，
偶去宇宙看地球，
我们能看，
好像就是我们，
反而是那个更渺小的存在，
地球看着我们的感觉，
我们现在在对话，
其实我是在未来的我，
回忆,
现在我们之间的对话，
其实我根本就没有现在，
现在处于未来了，
我在未来回忆现在，
回忆我跟周周跟老吴，
现在对话，
有意思，
我这么想说，
我现在好虚无的感觉，
我感觉我是一个电子的投射，
或者是我穿越了，
或者是我乘坐时光机，
回到了过去，
或者是我正在未来，
想着我的现在，
就是这样子。
我在一些自然场景里面的时候，
我也会感动，
也会感到非常的舒适，
但是我不会去思考，
我是否存在，
这个问题，
对,
然后刚才听你们讲完之后，
其实也挺受触动的，
我相信听众朋友们，
听到这儿的时候，
也会觉得，
好像,
自己的思绪又被打开了一点，
反而觉得，
如果你不会这么想，
反而是一种幸福，真的，
因为可能这一种感动，
它是一个特别复杂的情绪，
它可能是感动，
但也有可能是恐惧，
也有可能是绝望，
描述不好，
你在当下，
你看着那个美景，
也有可能是一种幸福的感动，
情感特别复杂，
觉得我们人类是，
挺孤独的一种存在，
虽然我们是有社交关系的，
我们是有信息的，
但是最终就是，
没有办法留下，
挺奇怪的，
很奇怪，
在我们思考人生的意义，
以及自己是否存在这件事的时候，
会让自己更珍惜当下吧，
我会更丰富的，
保寒情感的，
去过我的每一天，
去做每一件事情，
我会赛的一段时间，
说回来吧，
后面还有什么，
更有趣的数字呢，
还有三种改观，
一个是，
台湾人对我们大陆的改观，
第二个是，
在日本生活的中国人，
对中国人的改观，
三个是，
西方人对中国人的改观，
我就先来讲一下，
台湾人对大陆的改观吧，
我有一些对话来，
陈述,
第一个，
台湾人是一对，
在飞机上，
一对来自台湾的，
六十岁上下的，
恩爱老夫妻，
他们是，
跟这个台湾的旅行团来的，
因为他们英文不太好，
所以,
整个,
飞行的过程中，
都是我在帮忙照顾他们，
借此机会呢，
也就热聊起来了，
妻子说道，
她说,
台湾人对大陆人，
改观了很多，
但是,
她问我，
为什么大陆年轻人，
会有这样的变化？
他们是知道，
大陆人改变了，
年轻人在变化，
但他们不知道，
为什么变化？
我就回答了我的想法，
我说,
我们年轻的一代，
可能在老一辈人的托举下，
有了一个跳跃式的进步，
我们更加自由，
可以更加无忧无虑地，
做自己想做的事情了，
那么,
是过去打拼下来的一切，
造就了我们现在的一个词语，
叫做超稳定体系，
那么,
有了这样的一个经济基础，
接下来，
就是靠我们年轻人，
左上层建筑的事情了，
就是这样，
台湾人知道，
大陆在改进，
大陆的年轻人在变化，
但他们不知道，
为什么我们会有这样的变化？
其实,
我觉得也挺有意思的，
还有一个，
台湾人，
是我在罗福顿的一个咖啡店，
进来四位台湾人，
他们说要跟我拼桌，
然后我们就一起，
聊起来了，
他们很有意思，
两位男士，
两位女士，
男士是退伍军人，
女士呢，
一位是校长，
一位是老师，
所以我们，
理所当然，
就聊起来的教育，
他们跟我分享了，
台湾教育的现状，
然后我也分享了，
我们国内教育的现状，
然后,
然后我们又一起对比，
良性地对比了，
全世界一个教育的进程，
对比了，
北欧啊，
美国啊，
日本的教育，
后来我感觉很开心的事，
小见大，
他们看到了我，
看到了Ace，
然后跟我一起聊天，
他们才有更有机会，
去了解大陆，
了解大陆现在教育的状态，
他们说，
大陆的教育，
也有值得他们，
台湾学习的一面，
然后我觉得，
这也是很有意义的，
这是,
一个台湾人，
对大陆的改观，
第二个改观，
就是,
日本生活的中国人，
对中国人的改观，
这也是发生在，
冰岛雷克雅威克的，
一个青女，
公众厨房里那个时候，
我在傍晚，
我在边吃零时，
边写我的日志嘛，
就来了一位，
日本居住和工作的，
中国老伙子，
老爷子也不像，
因为他心态很年轻嘛，
就老伙子吧，
他自称自己为东营女人，
然后让我叫他Liu Sang，
又还是回到之前，
我们聊过的，
他就说，
这么多天下来，
他没有遇到过中国人，
然后也没有遇到，
更没有遇到过，
独自旅行的，
中国女性，
聊到女性的问题了，
他说我是第一个，
就说在他的印象里，
因为他在日本生活很久了，
他说在他的印象里，
白人的孩子很开朗，
亚洲很明天，
中国人更加了，
他就说，
可能也是因为他生活在日本太久了，
不太了解中国了，
然后他说，
见到我之后，
他说,
原来中国，
现在的年轻人，
也是更加开放了，
打开自己，
走出国门，
能够更加的去，
勇于表达自己了，
这是一个在日本生活很久的，
中国人对中国人的改观。
第三种改观，
就是西方人对中国人的改观，
我也遇到了很多有趣的人，
第一个就是，
在斯塔万格的民宿，
大概有很多，
来自不同国家的人吧，
晚上一边吃零食，
一边看电影，
一边聊天，
里面有一个人，
他屋主，
他是一名作家，
他很喜欢中国，
还写了一本叫做，
中国之旅的书，
他说他前两年，
环游了中国，
他会因为跟我的对话，
他说他会想，
再来一次中国，
可能会再出一本书，
他可能想用他的书，
去试图去改变，
整个挪威人，
对中国的一看法吧，
他说他有这样一个红月，
因为他很喜欢中国，
他特别喜欢吃火锅，
他说,
第二个西方人，
对中国人的改观是，
在冰岛发生的，
他的名字叫做，
克里斯多夫，
然后简称，
AKA,他叫KK,。
然后他是一名，
在冰岛生活的匈牙利人，
也是我在，
斯奈山班岛，
一日游的巷岛，
那次很奇怪，
之前我几次，
订的一日团，
当地一日团，
在那一次呢，
车上就是，
那对人可能都认识，
他们可能是一个，
中国的旅行团吧，
订了一辆小巴车，
来到冰岛，
然后订了这个小巴车的，
呃，旅社类似的，
然后我是唯一一个，
外来的，
订了这个小巴车，
没有任何人讲话，
然后KK就很尴尬，
没人跟他聊互动，
然后我就跟他一起唱歌，
然后一起干嘛干嘛干嘛，
然后他就问了，
他就说，
他觉得中国人，
好内向，
都不喜欢讲话，
然后他以前也带过中国的团，
说什么，
都不讲话的，
然后感觉一天下来，
还没有成就感，
什么什么的，
然后我就跟他说，
有没有可能，
是因为，
他们已经是个团了，
他们内部其实玩得很嗨呢，
是你自己融入不进去，
我跟他说，
然后,
呃,
这个是其，
还有一个很好玩的，
我也想分享一下，
就是KK,
因为我的外放，
KK说想带我们整车人，
去玩一些，
项目之外的景点，
我去玩了一个，
搬巨石挑战，
巨石上面写了一段话，
冰岛语写的，
他就说，
如果你成功搬起了这个石头，
你就可以留下来，
有资格在冰岛的餐厅里面打工，
然后我还成功了，
也不知道是不管里面，
他说,
我是当天到目前为止，
唯一成功的女性，
然后我感觉，
我又给我们中国人，
长脸了，
KK还给我分享了，
冰岛人的一个执念，
什么执念呢，
就是,
冰岛那边不是，
香蕉是热带水果，
对吗,
然后冰岛人的执念就是，
我因为香蕉太贵了，
我们一定要自己种出香蕉来，
所以他们那边有一个小镇，
阳光房的温室里面，
太阳能的，
在温室里面种了很多，
蔬菜水果都成功了，
五六年时间，
全冰岛终于种出了，
一颗香蕉树，
香蕉只有拇指这么大，
我们冰岛人，
能够种出超大香蕉，
他只有一颗，
全冰岛一颗香蕉树，
种出了拇指大小香蕉，
你看多有意思，
一个是对我们女性，
中国人的改观，
一个是原来冰岛的人，
也这么有意思，
咱们一直在想的是，
我们举国之力，
终于研究出了，
我们国人自己的芯片，
然后你一对比人冰岛，
我们终于，
种出了一颗香蕉，
太可爱了，
第三个，
地方人对中国人的改观，
是在我在芬兰，
第二星期机场转机的时候，
也是半夜了，
机场里面遇到了两位，
天天在全满世界跑，
拍冒险，
拍纪录片的两位大哥，
一位是美国老爷子，
65岁,
然后还有一位是德国小伙子，
27岁,
我也蛮动容的，
他说,
本来他们你都不想理我的，
我点了一个三个名字，
三位是我在那边吃，
太饿了，
Ace你知道吗，
你先对我们说，
这将是一个，
漫长的夜晚，
要等飞机嘛，
It's gonna be a long night,。
然后他就说，
你本来可以选择避开我们的，
因为毕竟机场凌晨没什么人，
他们俩又看起来这么像坏人，
他们就是胡思拉扎那种的，
没有贬义啊，
no offense,。
然后他说，
但是我没有，
但是你没有去规避他们，
然后你选择打开自己，
选择去认识我们，
然后他说，
这就是所谓的，
sirang deputy,。
就是这个词，
可能比命中注定，
就是所谓的designation，
什么更加高的一个境界了，
是你,
让我重新认识了亚洲人，
然后也是你，
让我们愿意去了解中国人，
他说,
也是你让我们放下了，
我们的傲慢和偏见，
就是他们原来是，
根本亚根就不想去理解，
亚洲人中国人的，
就是我们这种，
黄皮肤的人，
就他们也有自己的傲慢与偏见，
跟那本书也很像，
接下来还有一个鼠子，
一场球赛，
刚刚老我也提到过，
在意外之外的，
我不是一路北上吗，
抵达了特勒姆色，
那边有个叫做，
全世界最北麦当劳，
我吃好了，
一般般，
然后我就出来了，
不然看到我的右手边，
一个小的酒吧里面，
有一堆红色的人影，
在那边唱歌跳舞，
手舞主导，
很热闹，
我就进去，
问了很多人，
我说,
为什么你们这么多人，
在这边干嘛呀，
因为他们穿了球服，
其实我知道，
肯定是一个，
要么就是，
球迷见面会获得之类的，
才知道，
当天晚上七点，
有一场足球比赛，
它是一个，
欧冠下的一场比赛，
也是特勒姆色这个城市，
今年的第一场比赛，
对阵的是，
来自捷克，
这个国家的一座城市，
是国家城市之间的比赛，
是酒吧里面，
就是很多粉丝团，
在那边准备，
先开始预热了嘛，
敲落打鼓，
放音火，
反正我晚上，
我也蛮想去看的，
很心动，
正好挪威不是哈兰德，
挪威世界杯，
也很火，
我就请，
粉丝团团长，
把网址给了我，
然后我还问他们，
现在空的位置上，
哪个座位，
是最佳观赏点，
问了好几个粉丝，
最终选择的这个点，
去了,
真的是最好的观赏点了，
然后就买到了，
买到了超级好的位置，
我就一直跟这个，
球迷的粉丝团，
一路,
从酒吧，
马路上走啊走啊走，
前后还有警车引路的哦，
就为了这个粉丝团引路哦，
粉丝团团长，
送了我一条周边的围巾，
然后我还被，
当地的电视台，
采访了很久，
因为我是独特的面孔，
我还带了一顶，
绿帽子，
绿色冷帽，
一直采访我，
采访了很久，
就边走边采访，
边走边采访，
第二天，
我不是要离开了吗，
我走在街上，
还有半天时间闲逛，
我还被当地的居民，
认出来了，
他说,
我好像在电视，
电视里看到你了，
就是球赛的时候，
你是那个中国的，
小姑娘什么，
我说是的是的，
我虽然是个，
最渺小的一个个体的存在，
但是我也代表了
东方的一个最小单位，
真的好自豪，
好幸运看了球赛，
好幸运教他们中文，
好幸运被采访了，
好幸运被认出来了，
好奇特的机遇，
比单纯的徒步，
这个太宝贵了，
这太精彩了，
是是是，
就让李淳总结下来，
就是,
之前周末也有说过，
你有变成精神北欧人吗，
我感觉我真的变成了一个精神北欧人，
我们一直都会说，
欧洲的高铁不如我们，
对不对，
那么有没有可能是，
因为其实他们的国家很小，
很分散，就很很小嘛，
所以他们根本不需要浪费。
钱建高铁，
然后政府呢，
都把这部分钱，
花在了真正有需要的地方，
比如说，
公立图书馆，
体育场，
洗手间，
保护自然环境，
免费的教育，
福利待遇，
医疗,
和在性休假等方面，
对不对，
这是其一。
第二点呢，
就是,
我们有时候都会说，
哎呀,
国外的洗手间，
都是作弊，
不是尊弊，
不卫生，
但是你去了，
你可能才会知道，
他们在卫生清洁方面，
真的做到了，
百分百的负责，
非常继执，
每一个洗手间，
每一个位置，
都干净的不得了，
然后洗手间里的必须物品，
一应俱全，
而且你可以发现，
全北欧，
比如说全挪威，
全冰岛，
全芬兰，
洗手间里的用品，
都是有统一化的，
都是这个产品，
这个品牌，
一模一样，
然后我们都说，
国外的外卖，
不方便嘛，
比如说国内，
24小时,
你都可以点外卖，
而且速度非常快，
但是你去了，
你可能才会了解到，
他们国家的法律，
保护他们的人权，
到底下班，
你不下班，
老板催着你下班，
那么像这样的一个国家，
又怎么会需要外卖呢？
关于支付，
我们都会说，
国外支付不方便，
那么国内都已经无现金了，
扫二维码都可以了，
但是你有没有可能说，
你去了才知道，
他们都是用Apple Pay，
关于爱情，
我们有时候也会有，
思维定式啊，
说什么国外的爱情，
不纯粹啦，
看了那些美剧英剧，
会这么抉择嘛，对吧？
但是你有没有可能，
去了那边，
真实的播开剧情，
播开小说，
你去看真实的环境，
你就会看到，
八十多岁的夫妻，
一起途不旅行，
随处可见，
八十多岁，
九十多岁都会有，
一起途不旅行，
而且住的也是情侣，
我见了好几对，
跟我一起住情侣的，
八十多岁的老夫妻途不旅行，
然后你才会看到，
每天下午，
每周末，
家庭,
单位，集体出动，
去露营，
去海边晒背，
去玩耍，
去探醒，
因为我身边，
也会有这么多人，
这么认为国外的嘛，
所以我就把它讲出来了。
帮Ace去澄清一下，
因为我们，
并不是要，
刻意的去打造，
一个对比关系，
这个世界，
对于我们中国人，
是带有一定的，
思维定式的，
其实我们中国人，
对国外也是一样的，
唯一一个，
去打破他的，
只能通过你亲眼，
亲自,
去见到另一个世界，
你会发现，
他们的差异背后，
存在着某些合理性，
的时候，
你自己再去判断。
人都是有自力性偏差的嘛，
都会站在，
只会站在自己的角度，
去看待一个问题，
去分析一个问题，
去看待世界，
去看待别人。
对,
Ace有一个事儿，
我还挺好奇的，
因为我看了，
几篇,
你自己去做的，
公众号的内容，
发现了，
他的标题里面，
有一个，
理想的自我，
是一只独立的疯子。
这句话，
好像你在不断的重复，
这个对你来说，
是有什么，
更深的意义吗？
嗯,
理想的自我，
是一只独立的疯子，
我想,
分为,
一只,
独立的和疯子，
这样去解释，
就是,
一只,
可以说，
人也是物种，
人归属于自然，
它不特殊嘛，
然后,
我们是和，
其他生物一样，
是处于一个平等的关系，
那么我想，
表达的是，
人要尽为自然，
所以,
我们用一只，
形容动物，
我也用一只，
来形容我，
意味着我，
跟所有的生物，
平等,
我也要，
意味着我要，
去尽为自然，
这样的一个，
含义在里面，
然后,
独立的是，
因为我的个性，
那也是我的能力吧，
我想说，
独处,
能独立的自我，
解决问题，
你知道的，
no one is coming,。
就是,
最后,
本质上都是，
要依靠自己的，
然后,
所以独立的就代表，
我想表达，
就是,
人要向内求，
这样一个，
含义,
疯子,
就是,
我特别热爱这个世界，
太好奇世界，
和太想探索世界了，
所以,
我需要自救，
我选择成为一个疯子，
那么这个世界很疯狂，
我在疯狂的世界里，
成为疯子，
就不是疯狂，
而是清醒，
这是最真实的我嘛，
你会期待，
有那么一群，
这样的疯子吗？
如果有是最好的，
我还是蛮希望，
有一只两只，
或者是一群独立的疯子，
做一个独立的疯子的时候，
也会给你自己，
带来更强的力量，
自信,
你知道自己的能力，
知道自己的边界，
认识自己，
每一次你文章的结尾，
都会有一个there there，
它是一种，
固定的表达吗？
离与里面，
它其实有这样的，
一个意思的，
可以equal一下，
就是let it be,。
随它去吧，
好了啦，
没事的啦，
放心吧，
随它去吧，
这样的一个意思，
就是让我们放下，
不要借还，
顺其自然。
在你自己的表达里面呢，
它有一层别的意味吗？
我的意味可能更多的是，
加了一个前綴，
就是,
你想要的，
可以去努力，
努力好之后，
结果怎么样，
放宽心，
随它去，
就是这样子的。
不是躺平式的，
顺其自然，
是你做了之后，
结果不管是，
正向的，
还是,
没有结果，
或者是，
互相的，
都是好的。
通过这次，
聊天,
我觉得，
很鲜活的Ace，
就出现在我们眼前。
我们毕竟是一个，
定位在旅行的，
不可拦目，
有的时候，
我们不会特别深层次的，
跟人去聊一些，
内心的精神世界，
今天呢，
它是自然而然的，
因为我们在聊到，
有一些，
地点,
或者是，
某一些体验的时候，
这些东西，
就自然而然的，
流露出来了。
特别宝贵，
我觉得每一个人，
可能,
内心的世界里面，
都有一点点，
Ace的影子，
但是,
它很勇敢，
它把它表达出来。
下一步，
你有什么计划吗？
我觉得，
其实真的很有计划，
但是,
我还是有，
有点犹豫的，
我有两个选择，
最好是，
大家能够帮我选择一下，
不知道，
会不会有这个机会，
知道,
大家帮我的选择，
是什么样的？
哎，行啊，
我觉得，
能不能帮你，
选出一个，
最高票？
第一个选择是，
就是,
非洲的，
起立马扎罗雪山，
就它吧，
第二个也是很有意思的，
就是,
我以前，
西班牙不是有，
朝生之路吗？
我这次，
挺想去走，
西班牙，
法线徒步的，
大概800公里的样子，
需要花一个月的时间，
每天走，
所以,
这也是，
它有个800公里的，
水平距离，
爬升也是，
大概五六千米，
可能吧，
一个是，
大千喜，
西班牙的，
朝生之路。
听众朋友们，
也帮Ace,
来做一做，
你内心中的选择，
Ace,
体验过了以后，
还能回来，
再跟我们聊一聊，
反场,
这一期，
我和,
周周的角度，
已经获得了特别多，
而且,
也确实是，
给我们带来，
很多内心的力量感，
特别感谢，
Ace这一次，
给我们的分享，
那我们就结束了，
拜拜!